it's it's weird cuz I liked the Monica 3
series
I've watched I don't know which part I
got up to I watched a lot of it I mean
it's like [ __ ] many bro and I'm like
a monkey when I watch anime I don't want
to have to like think about like order
and a [ __ ] and you just put something on
and sometimes you'd like the I don't
know what happened in between the series
sometimes yeah and because it's so
confusing there was so many times I
would start a season of one of that
franchise I don't know which [ __ ] one
and I was like am I on the right one or
am I just confused because it's this
series like I didn't like easily the
most like that that is the number one
question I get past probably the most
what's the old what order should i watch
even that it's not even that common okay
but even even though if you're watching
in the right order it's such a confusing
show that normally you can get halfway
through the first episode of like season
2 right and you're like season 2 i
really like don't know what's going on
like well then i guess and i didn't have
any idea what's going on the whole time
so yeah that's the thing right is that
the monetary series like one season is
already confusing enough as it is like
in a enclosed story yeah and when you
look at it on the grand scale of things
it's even more confusing because
basically initiation pull the quentin
tarantino pulp fiction's yeah everything
is out of order but it's in the same
universe yeah i mean i don't think it
matters that much honestly as long as
you just get like this it's just [ __ ]
Google with the release order it's
stressful there oh man it's I've somehow
[ __ ] it up
many times like when I watched the thus
Spoke rohan cachet of EA's yeah for some
reason he Iraqi when he wrote them gave
them episode numbers in there and the
thing alright so when you're watching
the OVA s they don't do them in order
and but Iraqi never do them in order
anyway if I remember correctly so your
turn episode 1 they'll be like episode 6
and I'm like please stop you like
spacebar right [ __ ] Google right
which episode is episode 1
yeah episode 1 is episode 6 episode 2 is
episode 9 episode 3 is like episode 4
and then you'll like
why they like full people like a George
Lucas Star Wars right it's like Episode
four is the first one yeah at least it's
ghost episode water like three four five
six one two it's not even that it's just
like four nine two seven yeah that's
like why it's like this not nothing
just how hehe Suzumiya like did you
watch are you sorry when it was airing
yet so how he sees to me I had like this
broadcast order and it was it was full
absolutely no reason
it was just broadcasted in this random
order and people like I remember when it
was when I was airing people were like
oh this is like a genius move because
it's kind of like you're piecing
together the puzzle each episode and now
that it's like all aired now like I'm
pretty [ __ ] sure that they aired out
the order because the [ __ ] last
episode chronologically was just the
most anticlimactic episode of the entire
series so they're like are the best
episode is episode six
fix it up just just mix up the order and
people gonna call that genius crew so it
wasn't genius tiny Colnago was just on
crew way resist which is the original
Japanese broadcast yeah cuz tiny corner
girl was on a crack I didn't know that I
see I only watched it years after and
now you mentioned this before but I
watched the movie first by accident